à première vue la ferme de ce fait
marrer de son conjoint semble bien
normal des chevaux des ânes des lapins
des poules des poneys la famille compte
maintenant une trentaine de bêtes et
tous ont été sauvés on aussonne reiss
qui est ici qu'il m'eut c'est un code de
négligence on a travaillé pendant un an
pour le sortir de wes qu'il est et puis
on a payé le propriétaire pour être
capable de le récupérer
payer la négligence courant pour pouvoir
s'ouvrir l'animal on paie depuis six ans
leur ferme est devenu un refuge pour les
animaux maltraités ou abandonnés il ya
un besoin et y'a pas les ressources
on est à notre pleine capacité on
travaille à temps plein tous les deux on
écoutait aide financière on en a pas
il n'existe aucune aide financière du
gouvernement du québec pour les refuges
qui viennent en aide aux animaux de la
ferme
leurs propriétaires doivent débourser de
leur propre poche pour subvenir à leurs
besoins
cela représente des milliers de dollars
par année sans compter le temps consacré
à tenter de secourir les animaux
j'ai travaillé sur un corps pendant un
an où on a essayé de sortir les chevaux
de l'état dans lequel il était il ya une
jument qui en est morte
le mapaq était dans le dossier mais ils
vont pas gradation lorsqu'une plainte
pour un cas de maltraitance ou de
négligences animal est envoyé au mapaq
et celui ci intervient le ministère à un
réseau de partenaires à travers la
province qui prennent en charge les
animaux lorsque nécessaire mais
uniquement lorsqu'ils sont saisis le
ministère a traité 316 cas depuis le
début de l'année mais selon ce film
arrêts ce n'est pas assez que ce soit
avec les chevaux que ce soit avec les
êtres humains tout seul la lourdeur de
la machine fait que ça c'est positif
catherine gagneux qui possède 25 animaux
dans son refuge est du même avis j'ai au
moins cinq six appels par semaine
c'est presque tous les jours la demande
est telle qu'elle a décidé de construire
de nouveaux bâtiments pour accueillir
des animaux qu'est ce qui arrive avec
ses animaux il faudrait qu'ils aient de
l'aide mais ça c'est ça serait min et
âme dans la tente d'obtenir une aide
financière de la part du gouvernement
les refuges et parviennent à survivre
grâce entre autres à des dons du public
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
potton